you're more one Alive's good guys you're
more wanna Life's Good Guys hey apart
from when you're drunk apart from when
you're drunk sometimes the characters in
a movie believe something about another
character like this you're not Dull
you're nice that's what I thought and at
first is the viewer you accept that
belief at face value but then in
hindsight either thinking back over the
film later or watching it a second time
you end up questioning whether or not
the characters were right in that belief
ah don't take it like that don't take it
like that boring we're on your side the
first time I watched the Banshees of
Innis Sharon I just kind of accepted
products label as nice guy I mean column
definitely isn't the nice one but then I
watched the film a second time and I was
left with a lingering question is podic
actually nice is he really the good guy
this video is sponsored by mubi go to
movie.com thomasflight for your extended
30-day free trial
I love the movies that linger with you
sometimes it's an emotion sometimes it's
an idea sometimes you're left thinking
about the story and considering what the
movie was trying to say sometimes I
encounter a movie where the more I think
about it instead of coming to a clearer
picture of what is happening in the
movie The more I just end up with
questions the Banshees of insurance is
this way for me it's one of the best
acted movies from last year it's well
written and shot it's Darkly funny and
it presumably is a sort of allegory for
the Irish Civil War but I think
underneath all this it also explores
some of the darkest corners of the human
soul and tries to illustrate something
that at least to me seems to be haunting
many people in modern society but while
it engages in this thematic discussion I
don't think by the end of the film we're
left with a clear answer to the movie's
questions instead I think it functions
more as a kind of dialectic discussion
around a central conflict and so in the
spirit of this instead of me saying
specifically what I think this movie is
saying because I'm not sure exactly I
want to present five open questions I
have about the banshees of initi sharing
I used to think you were the nicest of
them
[Music]
turns out you're just the same as them
hey I'm the nicest of them
I think while the characters in the
movie paint the central conflict in very
binary terms where one side is kind of
the good guy and the other is kind of
the bad meaning I'm not sure the
character's actual Behavior really
reflects this consider how product is
extremely self-involved and obsessed
with this conflict to the point where he
immediately starts kind of mistreating
and ignoring the other people around him
nothing
for a Sherry oh she like it is it no
he holds a double standard for himself
and for others
and who's going to do the cooking oh
that's your first question is it who's
going to do the cooking well it wasn't
me first question was it but what about
me was me first question and seems to
make no attempt at genuine sympathy or
understanding for what calm or I think
almost more poignantly his sister
Siobhan is going through that was a book
it's sad sad
you should read a not sad when Siobhan
as you might get sad
hmm
now I'm not saying calm is the good guy
emporic is actually the bad one or that
product doesn't ever do nice things
all my heart I'll say sorry he loves his
animals he says nice things about his
sister he offers Dominic a place to stay
just the one night mind nice but the
movie doesn't allow the characters to be
the simple caricatures that the
community wants them to be similarly we
could ask if Colin is actually mean
consider his genuine tenderness and
defense of his friend at several moments
even after he said he doesn't like him
anymore and the passion for music he
clearly shares with the people around
him he's a character that can't simply
be reduced to the absurdity of the
ultimatum that he gives to podik I think
ultimately all the characters Behavior
challenges the labels the characters
give themselves and each other
um what's it called
the Banshees of inner Sharon I was
thinking
despite the film's title no one even
mentions banshees until this
conversation quite far into the film
where we learn the Banshees of inner
Sharon is the title of the song calm is
composing but there are no Banshees
I know I just like the double sh sounds
the most obvious Target for the label of
Banshee in the film I think is Mrs
McCormick in addition to the direct
references to her being a go-to because
she's a girl and her generally creepy
Vibe she also fits comb's description of
a banshee maybe there are banshees too
I just don't think that they scream to
partend death anymore I think they just
sit back
amused what are you smiling at and
observe she watches the events take
place in the film often with a kind of
passive amusement and of course in one
moment she actually portends the deaths
that happened in the movie the Death
Shall come true
really the only element of a banshee
that she doesn't have is the screaming
but I think Mrs McCormick might operate
as something a little bit more
interesting than just a literal Banshee
in the film I don't want to talk
don't go killing his dog now if we think
about the banshees being symbolic for
all the characters own pain and despair
we then can see how the different
characters interact with their own
repressed pain based on how they
interact with Mrs McCormick Park tries
to hide from it column sits and stews in
his despair
it beckons for Siobhan but she resists
and it happens off screen but Dominic
left without hope seems to give in
so who or what are the Banshees Mrs
McCormick is a constant presence for
these characters but is the movie
suggesting she is literally the Banshee
or is it using her to represent the way
the Banshees are really present in each
of the characters
[Music]
you can't just all of a sudden stop
being friends with a fella why can't I
why can't you because it isn't nice
whose side is Siobhan really on on the
surface we see her defending Park but I
think in the subtext of her Arc as a
character end in Kerry condon's
incredible performance there is a lot
more going on with her character the
first time I watched this moment for a
bit of Peace in my heart like
you can understand that
can't you
my interpretation was that Siobhan was
so fed up with column that she kind of
storms off in disbelief
can't you
but while I think Siobhan is angry and
fed up with the absurdity of calm's
antics there's something else happening
here that we can see on her face I think
Siobhan unlike parg actually understands
calm's Despair and the sort of
existential dread he's facing it's a
moment when she says this to comb would
you live on an island off the coast of
Ireland call him what the hell are you
open for like that I think she realizes
she herself is in the same predicament
and it sets off her own existential
spiral well is it crucify him you're
leaving hey no one's leaving when calm
says this don't worry sometimes just
entertaining myself
might I Stave off the inevitable
don't you
no I don't I think she really does
understand yeah you do
it's immediately after this that she
makes the decision to leave while she
doesn't support what column is doing she
ultimately does decide she needs to
separate herself from the environment
she's in which includes parg something
that calm is sort of trying to do in his
own Twisted way I think Siobhan sides
with Paddock But ultimately I think it
might be calm's position that she better
understands
the most interesting it's ever been I
think I like him again now
what is really going on with column is
he just behaving absurdly are you coming
out to the pub come did he just wake up
one day and choose chaos
there is a fundamental absurdity to his
position but I think trying to
understand what's going on with this
character underneath this absurdity is
Central to understanding the conflict at
the heart of the movie
for some reason calm doesn't seem to
mind Park when he's being more
aggressive and mean but why is this is
calm just masochistic well maybe a
little bit but I didn't understand this
part of the character until I understood
the connection between calm and Siobhan
and the similarities between the two
maybe he just doesn't like you no more
just don't like you no more at one point
Mrs McCormick says this I wasn't trying
to be nice
I was trying to be accurate and when I
first heard it I thought it was kind of
a puzzling statement why our niceness
and accuracy at odds well if calm sin is
being not nice then Park sin is denial
you do like me we see his denial and how
he treats Combs ultimatum he seems to
think he can just continue to talk to
calm without consequences even after
doing so has led to them once I finish
my party I'll bring it back to him
but I think most importantly he doesn't
seem to want to recognize any of the
negative emotions and pain that anyone
around him is experiencing maybe he's
just embraced
that's what I was thinking that he's
depressed
and if he is you could at least keep it
to himself like you know push it down
like the rest of us it's not just that
calm doesn't want to be around somebody
who's nice it's that parg's idea of
niceness contains an element of ignoring
the reality of other people's emotional
pain but she's a ninja and pretending
that everything is fine parig doesn't
want to rock the boat he doesn't want to
acknowledge sadness or loneliness or
despair where they exist what's the
matter with you not no matter what we
forgot
he's conflating his own niceness with
happiness they're nice that's what I
thought you know happy lad and I think
it's Park's denial of what column sees
as an accurate but painful truth about
life that causes the rift
pain and hurt is something I find in my
experience of culture almost never goes
directly talked about there is some deep
impulse at least in a lot of Western
culture but I think other places as well
to repress our own feelings of pain
instead of expressing them perhaps
because revealing your pain is often
seen as a kind of weakness something
society looks down upon or perhaps
because we often feel shame about our
pain as if it reveals some deep personal
inadequacy how's that despair despair
often isn't seen as a symptom but
something to confess in Secrets or
perhaps we don't talk about our pain do
you never get lonely Parikh
because others react poorly when we do
I go what
lonely
do I never get lonely
what's the matter with everybody
we don't want to feel like we're
burdening those around us
perhaps we don't believe that our pain
deserves expression my work on this
video was delayed by three full days
because of several migraines I had
something I deal with pretty regularly
and even now I'm hesitant to bring up
what is a relevant example from my own
life because talking about my own pain
here feels like Crossing some kind of
boundary I'm already feeling the need to
clarify that I'm not bringing this up to
illicit sympathy and there's an
immediate impulse to minimize my own
experience of pain because there's
others out there who I know are dealing
with more than I do but nonetheless
those three days where I wanted to work
but couldn't really do anything due to
my physical condition really sucked and
even mentioning that here feels deeply
personal almost inappropriate for a
video essay but this is my whole point
the reality of the pain we experience is
something we often go to Great Lengths
to hide from the public or the community
at large and sometimes even from those
who are closest to us and of course I
think it's nice and good to not want to
be overly negative and complaining all
the time and it's necessary to consider
when it is and isn't appropriate to talk
about your own pain and consider your
own experience in the context of what
other people are experiencing and not
burden others unnecessarily with your
pain but it's also possible for these
kinds of nice considerations to become a
sort of pathological denial
to get around the discomfort we have
with discussing negative emotions and
pain openly we often turn to art
here we can find expressions of strong
emotions both positive and negative in a
space where the artist feels safe to
express them this is one of the things
that just draws me to all kinds of art
because it's a space where strong
intense feelings that often get ignored
in our day-to-day lives or the
entertainment we consume get expressed
and it's here I realize that I've
written myself into a little bit of a
corner because even though I cringe
every time I hear this corny line from
the Nicole Kidman AMC intro heartbreak
feels good in a place like this I have
to admit that it's kind of a little bit
true watching movies we carve out a
space to explore not just heartbreak but
all kinds of painful emotions safely
contained within an externalized
narrative the artist feeling safe to
express their intense feelings through
the remove of Art and the viewer
identifying with those experiences and
perhaps feeling less alone seeing
someone Express a painful experience
that they recognize the problem with
unacknowledged pain is that it tends to
Fester like an untreated wound denial of
this pain doesn't make it go away it
simply postpones facing up to it when
denial of our own hurt is chronic and
widespread it boils over as conflict
looked here
whatever it is you're fighting about
openly acknowledging our hurt and
emotional pain isn't a Panacea that
immediately solves everything but it can
be a first step towards actually being
able to deal with the underlying
problems and understanding and relating
to each other on in a Sharon Paddock
isn't the only one in denial none of the
characters really seem to be able to
truly face their struggles head on
if Siobhan were able to acknowledge to
Parikh how lonely and sad she feels and
if colem could communicate his despair
directly instead of having to threaten
to chop off his fingers to get his point
across and people treated Dominic's
abuse as something more than a bit of
Gossip to be spread around and everyone
including parig was able to bravely face
this hurt and be nice and kind to each
other not due to an absence of the hurt
but in spite of it would the community
be able to tend to each other's needs
and care for each other and heal some of
these hurts and perhaps reduce them
by the end of the movie the characters
have changed column seems willing to
talk to patik again I think this is
because Colin recognizes the meaning and
value of true kindness that's in Paris
when potix saves his dog instead of
retaliating for Jenny because padig is
saving the dog not because he's ignoring
his own hurt but in spite of it and
podig sees the value of recognizing hurt
for what it is instead of denying it and
Siobhan has recognized how toxic this
environment was for her and took action
to make her life better but I'm still
left with questions are those things a
suggestion of growth in these characters
or is this story itself an absurd
tragedy of unnecessary conflict one that
we're supposed to sit back and watch
amused
the Banshees of initi Sharon was one of
my favorite films from last year and
another one of my favorite films
decision to leave by Park Chan wook is
available exclusively on mubi my sponsor
for this video movie is a hand curated
online streaming Cinema with an amazing
catalog of films from all around the
world you can get an extended 30-day
free trial when you go to mubi.com
thomasflight in the US they also
recently added to the collection another
great Korean film The Host by bonjun ho
the catalog is always expanding and I
love their focus on curation and
recommendation which makes mubi a great
place to discover something new to watch
check out my recommendations or just
explore the catalog when you sign up at
movie.com thomasflight again that's
mubi.com
thomasflight for your extended 30-day
free trial
foreign
[Music]